I think one was there was a idolizing of
unfettered markets and much if not most
of the intelligentsia were duped I
recalled traveling with my dear brother
Michael Harrington are talking with
brother Stanley Aronowitz years ago and
you know here we're engaging critiques
of unfettered markets and it looked as
if we were we were medieval thinkers
everybody was saying we're followers of
Milton Friedman everybody was saying
Frederick Hayek got it right everybody
was saying market eyes commercialized
commodify and we were still reading
Lukesh and Lukesh was saying
commodification is not simply an
asymmetric relation of power of bosses
Vasavi workers or workers are being more
and more marginalized profits are being
produced wealth is being produced imaged
at the top
no fair distribution of that wealth or
profit for workers poor are being
demonized because they are viewed as
those persons who are irresponsible who
will not work who are always looking for
welfare ie failures in the society of
success and we reach the brink and the
chickens came home to roost and a few
years ago the unfettered markets led us
off and over the brink and all of a
sudden very few intellectuals want to be
honest and acknowledge the degree to
which they were duped don't want to talk
about the inequality that went along
with it don't want to talk about the
demonization of the poor that went along
with it
don't want to talk about the pollak
politics of fear that produced a
Republican Party that was more and more
lily-white using not just race but also
demonizing gay brothers and lesbian
sisters don't want to talk about the
indifference toward the poor and greed
being good and desirable and so forth
now it's a very different moment and
it's not you know just about a pointing
fingers but say somebody's got to take
responsibility for this was a nearly
40-year run who paid the cost
as usually the case little poor working
people played the cost disproportion
black and brown and rang it easy
so in the Age of Obama we say okay can
we have a different kind of discussion
and that's what we're trying to do but
of course you got two wars going on
you've got still Wall Street in the
driver's seat in the Obama
administration when it comes to the
economic team and you've got very you
know I think in some ways unimaginative
thinking when it comes to foreign policy
be at the Middle East a big European
Union a big Latin America you know call
it Chavez a dictator that man has been
elected if he's if he's calling him if
he's calling into question the rights
and liberties criticize him as a
Democratic president we did the same
thing for Bush Bush was calling the
question rights and liberties we didn't
call him a dictator we said he's a
democratic elected president who's doing
the wrong thing Chavez ought to be
criticized he's not a dictator demands
been election but it's that kind of
demonizing that obscures and office
gates the kinds of issues that are
necessary because Chavez is also talking
about poor people of course I want
libertarian and Democratic side I want
right to liberties and empowerment of
poor people but talking about poor
people is not a joke it's crucial it's
part and parcel of the future of any
serious Democratic project the
fundamental question of any democracy is
what is relation between public
interests and the most vulnerable that's
the question that is the question the
test of your rule of law is going to be
how are the most vulnerable being
treated it's not whether the torturers
are getting off we know the torches
don't have rule of law applied to them
the wiretapper they're getting off
scot-free
what about Jamal with the crack back
taking the jail for seven years oh so
you got a different rule of law when it
comes to Jamal on the corner versus your
torturers and your wiretap errs torture
is a crime against humanity it's not
just illegal wiretapping is illlegal say
that's not a crime against humanity cuz
a minyan sure I've had my phone tapped
for years I don't think they come in to
crime against you matter you just ought
to quit doing it got there
I think it'd keep you in mind Amina
demos as always a heterogeneous diverse
got a lot of xenophobic elements among
the team mostly a lot of ignorance a lot
of parochialism you also have a lot of
cosmopolitanism a lot of globalism a lot
of courage moral courage
so the demos is not one thing but when
it comes to the ability of the demos to
organize mobilize and bring power and
pressure to bear we certainly are in a
crisis our system is broken
we've got 71 percent of people who want
universal health care and you can barely
get through a reform bill with a weak
public option it's clear lobbyists from
the top
pharmaceutical companies drug companies
have tremendous influence much more than
the demos from below you see so that
those those preferences don't get
translated easily because our
politicians are beholden to that big
money and that big influence um but I
mean the demos is still around thank god
you got your own institution for
dialogue dialogue is the lifeblood of a
democracy we got to allow ideas to flow
you have to expose people to different
visions alternative arguments and so on
they try to keep the torch of the
progressive demos alive but it's very
difficult to to organize it complacency
is deep apathy is deep people are
wondering how can you confront you know
big finance big government tied to big
finance when all you got is these little
people who are willing to talk and so
forth but they have tremendous power
bringing serious pressure to bear we can
March you know we marched against the
war by the millions
we were ignored by the bush
administration went to jail
we were ignored we couldn't translate
the foreign policy that happened
sometimes it was different Vietnam
you